we had this big story from Breitbart Bud
Light marketing executive Daniel Blake
on leave after Dylan Mulvaney ad
campaign ladies and gentlemen two
different Marketing Executives have been
placed on leave by the company
you know what's really crazy instead of
just saying we're sorry they just
removed two people which is a huge
Victory I gotta be honest I'm happy to
hear it but they can't apologize
they put out a patriotic uh ad Tim that
that was it I have apologized what else
yeah it's like the next day and it was
like sidestep the entire I gotta I gotta
give a shout out to John Oliver who I
think is as dumb as a box of rocks but
had a good joke he was like I think it
was Oliver he said the commercial was
basically typing in America Freedom
Patriot sorry and that's what would come
out and I'm like it's actually pretty
good like that's that's basically what
they did and they they tried doing the
911 thing like insult to injury the
apparently they had this the Clydesdale
commercial after 9 11 with the bud or
whatever I don't remember that I mean
but uh so that's what they did in this
new one the Clydesdale is running and
then it runs past New York and there's
like those who never forget and it's
just like dude you're not you're not
getting out of that by saying 911.
please don't use uh
yeah
I mean we've downplayed 911 you know so
much might as well just throw it in the
bud light apparently so it's what you
need to do when you have to apologize to
what you don't like so I will say my
only thing I've said this before is that
both of these people are on leave they
are not actually fired a lot of people
view this as a step towards being fired
but I just think they'll put them in the
background for a little while they'll go
to the Bahamas they'll hang out and then
they'll come back they're hoping to keep
these people in place I think the first
lady got fired for hiring domovany and
the second guy got fired for that stupid
horse commercial
but they're not fired well okay that's
what I mean like I mean like removed I
thought the first girl got fired
they were both placed on leave which is
ambiguous it means that like when you
guys are tired of being mad at us we'll
bring them back you know the other big
news today oh sorry go ahead I'm gonna
say the other big news that don't
mulvania hasn't posted anything since
the seventh that's interesting right
Dylan was posting almost every day or
every other day and just stopped posting
when this whole thing kicked off so I
just want to say like
I think Dylan Mulvaney is a person who
doesn't have anyone who cares about them
and that deeply worries me like anybody
who is in Dylan mulvany's life would be
saying stop this this is this is not
acceptable it's not okay they're being
driven by The Tick Tock algorithm into
like look Dylan Mulvaney came out an
interview and said how come no one's
messaging me to date like clearly the
machine is pushing down in a direction
that regular people are not interested
in and the people who love and care
about Dylan or maybe there's nobody are
not doing anything to help Dylan with I
mean Mulvaney was even just interviewed
in that article where you know
she was talking about I don't think
domovania's Trends yeah yeah
I don't know what we're allowed to say
here this isn't my YouTube channel so
I'm just trying to be extra safe here
well let me just say it real quick so
you can make your point Dylan Mulvaney
does not in my view I'm not a doctor
exhibit any of the traditional Jenna
dysphoria or a AGP or AAP which is what
is typically associated with uh
transgenderism publicly
Neil Mulvaney made a video singing about
looking at his bulge which is clearly
the opposite of AGP or gender dysphoria
it seems like Dylan Mulvaney is just
mocking trans people to get views
because the algorithm keeps promoting it
yeah I mean look I think when you have a
giant marketing firm that throws
somebody like this out into the public
eye the public absolutely has the right
to comment on it and the public
absolutely has to write to say what they
think is Despicable about it that said I
do feel bad I mean I I feel bad for him
because
this is someone who's clearly
got something wrong with them this is
not normal healthy behavior in general
well I I I I I I I think I say I half
agree okay but continue I'm not saying
that there's no agency there I'm saying
someone has something wrong with them
and you made this point about no one
being in their life who cares about them
I remember a long time ago
I had a friend who was watching uh some
of these American Idol cringe
compilations where someone who is really
bad at singing is intentionally selected
to be on the show so they can sing
poorly and the audience can laugh that's
how it works and that's yeah what he
said was I don't think these people have
anyone in their life who loves them and
that's essentially what we're seeing
they're not enough
Truth for the American Idol thing and
it's it's so many other facets of life
there are people who are they genuinely
think their friend can sing they're like
you're so good you should go yeah and
then they go and so I've had friends
who've tried it for American Idol and
when they explain to me the process they
were like oh like all the bad singers
you see
half the time they're not even in the
room with the without with the judges
what they'll do is they'll record the
bad singers in front of a camera and
then they do a cut that makes it look
like the judges are in the same room but
they're not they're watching a video
screen of it so they're not actually
saying but sometimes they are and that
means that the producers go to the bad
thing and say we want you to sing in
front of the judges it's intentionally
done I think for Dylan Mulvaney
you said there's something something
wrong with them
I don't necessarily I think it's I think
it's total agency I think what's what's
wrong with Dylan is narcissistic
personality disorder I think everything
that Dylan is doing is an active choice
to pretend to be trans and there's more
evidence to suggest that Dylan is Faking
It Ali London has produced previous
interviews and recordings showing that
Don mulvania has lied about when he was
transitioning and other trans people
have come out on YouTube videos saying
Dylan is clearly not taking estrogen
despite saying on two different
occasions that he had started taking it
at two different times so not only does
he contradict himself but these other
trans YouTubers have said it doesn't
look like he's even taking estrogen at
all based on on his body it makes it
even more bizarre to me because Dylan
did undergo serious plastic surgery
right like I think they've explained it
no no no no that's been explained too
apparently I don't know if this is true
but people have pointed out that Dylan
did not get facial hair removal just
facial slimming which is not that can
easily is more easily reversed meaning
if Dylan ever decided just to go about
living not as a woman or whatever or
doing this publicly Dylan would very
quickly look male again I mean what if
this is over like this uh Bud Light or
Budweiser thing came out on as to Mark
300 65 days of girlhood right this one
year mark is when all of this happened
what if in another week Dylan comes out
and is like I tried it but you guys are
so hateful I'm just gonna go live as a
man and you guys are bigoted and
terrible at this point the corporations
are taking full advantage of him and I
you know but no problem I don't want to
touch him at this point right but Tim
brought up the point that he hasn't
posted in how what three weeks since the
seventh so so it's been a while like you
said he was consistently posting but I
what I view with this whole entire thing
is again corporations taking advantage
of mentally ill people and I don't say
that in you know like I mean yeah in a
disparaging way I'm not trying to be
hateful here when I say that but yeah
very clearly if you are cross-dressing
if you think that this is how women
behave if you think that this is normal
behavior in society and a lot of people
do because we've hyped it up instead of
telling people the truth which is why
you have all of those viral clips of
Matt Walsh and Michael Knowles when they
do speak to transgender people because
they're very clearly telling them the
truth and the transgender Community can
never argue their their points properly
as to what it does feel like to be a
woman I can't even explain what it feels
like to be a woman and I am a woman
because it's not a feeling it's
something that you're born with right
you're either a man there's no uh
there's no reference point yeah exactly
and so this is just corporations taking
full advantage of uh easily manipulated
people Tim I was talking with you about
the United Airlines transgender that was
platformed given all of the affirmation
put into an advertisement and ended up
offing themselves because of I don't
know whatever pressure and you know I
was actually in front of scotus for the
trans day of Vengeance that got canceled
as well I was speaking to a transgender
woman who was basically saying oh yeah I
self-harm to get attention because I
want to be visible and that's why the
trans Community
um
I think this is one of the the big
issues with what we're seeing with Bill
Mulvaney first that what I see in Del
Mulvaney is narcissistic sociopathy not
gender dysphoria one the the people who
are experiencing gender dysphoria
they're not doing what Dom will then he
does dancing around in the woods in high
heels and singing look at my bulge over
and over again and keeping facial hair
and other things like that
what's happening is these big Tech
platforms like Jack Dorsey said all
those years ago were concerned about
suicide rates so they started offering
up social media protections for these
people which was then quickly exploited
by people who want fame and attention
but don't want to get any penalties so
let me explain it this way
if you post right wing memes on social
media let's say before Elon Musk bought
Twitter you were banned Carpe dongtum
was banned and broke no rules but you
don't post those memes
but if so how do you exploit human
emotion for clicks and Views and avoid
getting banned you do it from the left
the easiest path is exactly what Dylan
Mulvaney is doing the algorithm proves
it when you look at Dylan's earliest
content it was animals it was Dylan on
The Price is Right and then when Dylan
made a trans video boom that's when he
started getting traffic started getting
Fame and he chased after it well
remember the video too that came out
where he was like oh I can't find any
rules as uh I can't even remember what
he said but he was basically like oh my
friend wrote a role for me as a more
like trans feminine person and you know
again like he has been trying to adhere
to this he did find Fame in this and it
does seem like he has stuck to this and
he is really uh you know taking it as
far as he can yeah I think the issue
with that was that uh Dylan had
previously said
that they were trans deleted the video
and then later once again came out as
trans like the whole thing was staged as
like it was a fake coming out I guess
one thing I'll say about this is that I
don't even like being exposed to this
the fact that kids are exposed to this
is what bothers me that's Tick Tock the
most yeah so do we ban tick tock
I so the legislation that Republicans
were pushing to ban Tick Tock from what
I understand did some other things that
we might not be in love with but I think
that there is a real question to explore
there about banning Tech I I would not
be against it on principle you'd but
you'd have to show me good legislation
yes I really important I think the
legislation is yeah how do we do it as
the issue but I think it is a good idea
I would I think we should yeah but you
you would have to give me something that
really will expand it instead of lying
to me if we look at what Tick Tock
really is it's China subverting our
country that is what it is point blank
again you guys have talked about this
multiple times uh what are the children
in China targeted with on Tick Tock
versus the children in the United States
of America it's like night and day so it
is
they don't actually have Tick Tock and
China they have something similar called
something else and it does but owned by
the same company that owns Tech talk
right like I'm not entirely sure maybe
maybe I just know that there aren't all
companies in China basically controlled
by the CCP anyway so it's
between like November and Germany this
wave of like 25 Governors who were like
you are not allowed to have tick tock on
a state-owned device because part of the
user agreement is that it can collect
all this data including whatever else
you have on your computer like your
browsing data and things like that so
like if you are a government employee
and you have some sort of like someone
who works at the DMV right and they're
pulling up whatever and then they decide
to watch tick tock on their computer
like they have now exposed your data to
this this company that has to report
data to the the CCP under a 2017
National Intelligence law yeah like I
don't really think that we need this and
I know people say like oh Free Speech
things like that like build a competitor
have something else like I'm not saying
you can't say the things that you say on
Tick Tock I just don't want that
technology uh that is serving a
different entity it's not serving the
people of the United States in the
country thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time